by the time I graduated high school
doors were opening for an acting career
and I thought I might as well keep this
this career going and the doors that
were opening were lining up with what
was happening to me on the inside I want
to be about things that promote faith I
want to be about things that promote
family and marriage and Here I am
looking in the rearview mirror saying
this has been awesome
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sundays special I'm really
excited to welcome to the show Kirk
Cameron Kirk is an actor and producer
you remember him as Mike Seaver on
growing pains but he's also starred in
fireproof and way of the master he's
currently on a 30-city tour for his
marriage and parenting conference living
room reset now quick reminder we'll be
doing some bonus questions with our
guest the only way to get access to that
part of the conversation is to spend
money on us by becoming a subscriber
that's how we hold you up for the cash
going over to daily wire comm become a
subscriber you'll have access to all of
the full conversations with every one of
our awesome guests correct thanks so
much joining me showed yeah man it's my
honor great great - great to meet you
great to be here with you I gotta say my
entire family grew up on of course you
as Mike sieve really ingrown pads oh
yeah oh yeah well and this is kind of
crazy because my family's kind of grew
up with you on YouTube you're quite the
hit and and and and legend and subject
subjective of debate and passion
conversations in our house I really
appreciate you yeah I have to say I was
kind of insulted that you know I have a
name profile and yet my wife was far
more excited that you're coming on the
Sunday special that I actually host the
Sunday special well you know I it is it
is fun and it's funny
so many people grew up in the 1980s with
growing pains and shows like like that
and who's the boss and other kinds of
shows and it just you just feel like
these people grew up with you in your
living room so it's like their family
let you feel like you know them exactly
for me was the Fonz
it was Henry Winkler and you know I was
pretty excited when I met him so in a
second I asked you about what happened
while you're producing what while you
were on growing pains and your and your
shift to Christianity because that was
obviously the defining feature of not
only your life but also of your move in
your career I'm asking about that in
just a second but first let's talk about
a simple fact that is governments can
manipulate how much money is worth they
do this on a fairly routine basis
they're constantly inflating the
currency or deflating the currency China
for example has been manipulating their
currency for a while now that has a real
impact on your savings well now is the
time to get in touch with the folks at
Birch gold why well they allow you to
diversify out of just the currency and
into something that actually stands up
to government manipulation right now
they're putting out an offer I've never
seen it's the silver stocking stuffer
event when you contact Birch gold group
this month to buy precious metals once
you complete your purchase before
December 20th Birch gold will send you
free silver it's a great stocking
stuffer or Hanukkah
have a conversation with a birch called
expert see if precious metals that make
sense for your family birch gold they've
been with us since the very beginning I
know the guys I trust the guys and you
can ask them all your questions until
you feel comfortable and then once you
do open your account with Birch gold
group today you can get free 100 percent
silver you can even get a copy of their
no obligation free information kit Birch
gold group they've got thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews and a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau would be smart of
you to diversify make sure you're
protecting yourself against the
vicissitudes of the market it's worth it
just X been to 47 47 47 claim your
eligibility for this special offer today
again text Ben to 47 47 47 so let's talk
a little bit about what has become sort
of the defining feature whenever there's
an article about you and the press it's
always about your shift to Christianity
while you were playing Mike Seaver on
growing pains which was a radical shift
at least from the outside just because
the character of Mike Seaver is so
different from somebody who had become
an evangelical Christian so so what
exactly happened you and what was that
experience like well I didn't grow up in
a religious home so I never went to
church in fact I thought that that Jesus
was part of a different Trinity the
Easter Bunny the the Tooth Fairy and God
so that was never on the radar but I
actually met a girl on the set who was
really cute and she invited me to go
meet her family and it was a Sunday
morning at church and I heard a message
from the minister that just was just
answering questions that I was asking
existential questions philosophical
questions and and I got thinking about
the fact that one day I would die and if
really intelligent people believed in
the existence of God maybe I'm wrong as
an atheist and and at least I ought to
reach out and I heard this message of
God's grace and his love and his
forgiveness and I remember sitting in my
sports car on the side of the road at 17
years old and I thought about I could I
could get hit by a drunk driver I could
die today and if what that man said is
true
I'm not going to heaven because of my
attitude you know I was the big man on
campus I was Mike Seaver on growing
pains and and everything was on my terms
but I understood that a relationship
with God would have to be on his terms
he's the creator and so I remember
praying
and asking God to show me the way and
somebody gave me a Bible I started to
read it I started to go to church and
asked a million questions let's listen
to guys like Ravi Zacharias who I loved
that interview that you had with him
listening the guys like John MacArthur
and and and others who really got me I
was captivated by the message of the
gospel and I wanted to live my life in a
way that was different
saying thank you to the one that gave me
air to breathe water to drink and and I
was 17 so as a 17 year old kid trying to
figure out your own identity I know I I
ruffled some feathers I know that I may
have been like a bull in a china shop my
words may not have been seasoned with
all the grace that they should have at
17 but I was trying to figure out how do
I do this I I didn't grow up like this
how do I honor God in an industry that
doesn't always look to accomplish the
same goal how did your parents react to
moving in this direction well it was
interesting because my mom had gone to
church as a little girl but my dad
didn't want us to go to church he wanted
us to sort of you know figure it out
ourselves and so she was thrilled she
was like great I would love to go to
church but the problem was my mom and
dad were separated at the time and
providentially this news of me going to
church actually brought my dad to church
and my mom was like you're not going to
the church with the kids without me I'm
coming back and so that actually was one
of the things that I think added to them
reconciling their relationship and and
then we were all coming together and we
were praying together and going to
church together and it was a really
beautiful positive thing in our family
it's an amazing thing so how are you
received in the industry when you decide
to make this move me both my parents
work in the industry I spend a lot of
time around people in the industry I
know that when my mom she has formed
there for kids in our family and she
works at a very high level in terms of
business production I remember when she
would go to events and people would ask
how many kids she had and should say
four people would lose their minds they
would freak out so negative so many kids
already in the Orthodox Jewish community
where I spend my life like what happened
where the other seven yeah you guys get
with it so what was the reception liked
it to your to your move well
I would say that there were there were
some people who had a healthy concern a
natural healthy concern you know when
you hear of teen celebrities child
actors often things enter into their
life that make them go wrong and you
know that can be very concerning so I
was like what is he into what's going on
but it was kind of funny because really
I think the changes were I just wasn't
dropping as many f-bombs you know I
wasn't going to the same parties and I
and I wasn't interested in some of the
stuff that my friends were interested in
and I think over time it's really served
me well so there may be some parts that
I that I had to pass on because of
content or or conscience issues but at
the end of the day look at me I'm
sitting here with Ben Shapiro on your
show married for 29 years I have six
kids I'm working on projects that I'm
passionate about and I'm trying to
spread a message of life and light and I
think all that is because God has
pointed me in a direction that I think
works
did the offers start to change and I've
talked to a lot of conservatives in the
industry and you can see for some of
them they'll say no it didn't really
change I'm still getting the same offers
remembers talking to Patti Heaton about
this my friends and Patti I said to her
you know have you lost parts because of
this and because she's so pro-life and
outspokenly so and she said I don't
think so but let me call you back she
called me back 48 hours later she said
yeah I just found out I lost seven
specific parts because because so did
you feel any blowback from the folks in
the industry or is it something where
was sort of a natural progression toward
more parts he wanted to do I think I
think it's the latter I think that there
were doors that were opening up that
were just fantastic so I wanted to do
I guess I began to see I always wanted
to be a doctor I could say this way I
wanted to be a doctor I wanted to be a
surgeon my plan was to go to college go
to medical school and this acting thing
took off when I was nine years old by 14
I was on growing pains by the time I
graduated high school doors were opening
for an acting career and I thought I
might as well keep this this career
going and the doors that were opening
were lining up with what was happening
to me on the inside I want to be about
things that promote faith I want to be
about things that promote family and
marriage and
the movie fireproof came up and that was
a chance to be a part of a really cool
inspiring movie I was part of a
documentary called monumental which
explored the the founding principles of
our forefathers the pilgrims and I
retrace their escape route out of
England to Holland where they spent all
those years with their pastor before
coming over on the Mayflower and so it
wasn't ever like I felt that people's
disagreements with my faith or my my my
values was inhibiting my career I felt
like my clearer direction of where I
wanted to go was lining up with the
doors that were opening and and and Here
I am looking in the rearview mirror
saying this has been awesome
so how did you not get screwed up I mean
I know a lot of kids who are child
actors my cousin actually was it was a
child star mara Wilson choosin Matilda
and and miracle oh yeah and Miracle on
34th Street and all that yeah very sweet
person I haven't talked to her in a
while though but but a lot of other
people who start off as child actors
have serious problems in their lives and
you see these these horror stories all
over the media all the time so why
didn't that happen to you well then you
got to remember as far as me not being
all screwed up I'm an actor I could be
faking this whole thing turn off the
cameras you know I have friends
contemporaries people that I worked with
growing up that have had things happen
to them that didn't happen to me I'm
fortunate in some ways they've made
choices that are different than the
choices that I've made but in the end I
think I I was surrounded by some good
people the cast of growing pains was
great Allan and Joanna and Tracy and
Jeremy and Leonardo DiCaprio and it was
like we were really like a family and
and you know even to the point where you
know people didn't want to smoke on the
set people didn't want it to be hustling
on this site because it was kids there
and that combined I think with my mom
and dad just really just being there my
dad's a schoolteacher he taught physical
education and mathematics for 30 35
years and my mom was just always there
with us and I think those things sort of
laid a foundation
but being a teenager in Hollywood is a
pretty dicey road to take and I think
that's where faith in God kicked in and
pointed me in a different direction and
I took the road less traveled so to
speak but again I I think that sense of
wow I'm really blessed to have this life
and I want to live it in a way that
honors the one who gave it to me and I
think that kept me on track more than
anything do you still keep in touch with
people who you were on the show with oh
yeah yeah Jeremy comes over and cooks
every once in a while he's a chef he's
awesome and I see Tracy and Jeremy
probably the most of them as you know
alan thicke passed away
Joanna's up in Santa Barbara but we're
still friends and we love seeing each
other when we do have a chance so you've
been making you know Christian content
and conservative content or at least a
traditionally oriented family con down
for a while why do you think it is that
it's been left to sort of non mainstream
outlets in Hollywood to do all of that
it's been a constant source of
frustration for a lot of conservatives
that I know that the studios will spend
hundreds of millions of dollars on
movies that have an incredibly select
audience of apparently very blue people
living in very blue areas and they just
ignore an entire swath of people who
believe in religious faith and that's
left to sort of smaller studios to
distribute fireproof is of course the
best example of this a movie that was
made on a shoestring budget and then
goes on to do 30 million dollars at the
box office because Hollywood completely
ignores this entire segment of the
American population it's perplexing
isn't it I travel all around the country
teaching on the subject of marriage and
parenting because I think family is so
important I think I think when the
family crumbles the nation crumbles and
what I find everywhere that I go is that
there are people of faith I call it the
family of faith everywhere who believed
in the kinds of values and and and think
that character and virtue is essentially
important more so than politics more so
than the economy more so than these
other things and I don't know why there
aren't more projects like this but I
think that there are becoming more and
more of these things more more with
technology being the way that it is you
don't have to depend on a studio
tribution system you don't have to
depend on studio funding you can grab a
camera and you can have a YouTube
channel and you can start making stuff
more independent movies are coming
around this way I would think actually I
would love to ask you that why you think
I wonder if there aren't political
reasonings behind all of that I mean I
certainly think there I wrote a book in
2014 about the TV industry called
primetime propaganda about the and I
wouldn't interviewed probably a hundred
different executives and producers and
creators on yeah on TV shows and and
they many of them would say openly that
they had legitimate scorn for people in
the middle of the country with whom they
disagreed on these these sorts of areas
they felt that the real issues that were
perplexing people were not issues of
faith that wasn't that though those
weren't the people that were speaking to
and a lot of that was because the I
think the artistic endeavor from where I
said very much seems to be in from
people was talking to reflective of the
people who surround you so when I talk
to you see how the creators of friends
in which is a lifestyle completely
foreign to my own and formed a lot of
people who know the country right people
who are in their early 30s acting like
they're 17 years old living in an
apartment together all single right have
a kid at one point out of wedlock
disappears for several years the kids
sort of shows up randomly several
seasons later and and that's treated as
perfectly normal
they make a joke of it in the show and I
remember talking to Marta Kauffman who
is one of the creators of friends and
and she said right but that was those
are the people who I who I'm surrounded
by and so in other words the bubble that
you live in really defines the people
who you're speaking to and so because
the creative industry is drawn so much
from LA New York San Francisco and so
little from Ohio and Iowa that's right
there just aren't a lot of stories that
are being told from Ohio and Iowa which
is why there's this broad kind of gap in
the market so so so what seems like
there's such fertile ground for so many
of these projects with this underserved
market and that's what I'm trying to do
I would love to be a part of more movies
more television shows documentaries live
events I love being in front of people
so I love traveling I love getting
onstage I love I love performing I think
probably because I was on growing pains
all those years but I find that people
are looking for things to nobody wants
to fail at family right nobody nobody
goes to the altar thinking hey if this
whole thing blows up I'm okay with it we
want marriage to work we want parenting
to work and parenting is hard my wife
and I have six children for them a
adopted and so we have all we
a very diverse group of people in our
home and I think people want and
appreciate things that help them live
life in a way that that just causes
people to flourish families to flourish
and the nation to flourish so I'm going
to ask you about the family and
parenting stuff which is really where
you're putting most of your time at
these days but first you've heard about
cryptocurrency and you thought that
sounds weird crypto and currency why are
they in the same word well the reason
they're in the same word is because
effectively speaking what cryptocurrency
is is a digital way for you to protect
your assets why what is it well they've
created a thing called blockchain and
then they create a cryptocurrency and
then government's can't manipulate how
much that currency is worth it is just
up to the free market well with eToro
you get access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies with
transparent trading fees all in one
easy-to-use app eToro is smart crypto
trading made easy eToro social trading
platform has over 11 million traders
they facilitate over a trillion dollars
in trading volume per year globally you
can access the world's best crypto
currencies they've got 15 different
coins available
they've got low and transparent fees and
you can try before your trade they'll
give you a virtual portfolio with
$100,000 budgets you can see how this
thing works before you put your own
money into it you'll never miss a
trading trend with charts and pricing
alerts now I think the crypto currency
is definitely worth considering as part
of your portfolio again it's a good way
for you to defray some of the risk of
being in the stock market for example
sign up today at eToro comm slash
Shapiro that's et Oro comm slash Shapiro
so you've been married for what 20 he
said 29 years 49 years okay and you met
your wife on the set yeah my wife on the
set
she actually played Mike severs
girlfriend I like to say that I stole
Mike severs girlfriend away from you
know he had excellent taste and we've
been married for 29 years she's from New
York I'm from Los Angeles East Coast
West Coast so is sort of like a meeting
of two worlds but when I met her I found
that she was not only beautiful on the
outside she was just beautiful on the
inside she she loved God she loved kids
she loved family and we hit it off and
within a year we were married hey so how
old were you guys got married well I was
20 when I got my so I engaged proposed I
think it was 19 well yeah so I was just
like if I don't ask this girl to marry
me somebody else will I
and I cannot lose her oh yeah no that
that by the way folks this is where we I
mean we agree on a lot of stuff but
there's one area where you totally agree
if you ever find the girl who you think
you're gonna marry just propose like
right there so how long did you guys
date before you before you were
proposing well I think it was probably
maybe maybe even maybe six to nine
months yeah so it wasn't it wasn't all
that long yeah but I just I just knew
that like just I I'm not ever ever gonna
do better than this exactly no you took
your time I proposed my wife three
months in yeah it's done twelve years
coming up in July so that's the it's so
funny when we when we got engaged I had
told her I love you a month before she
said I love you back to me so is a real
awkward month right yeah I would finish
every conversation I would say I love
you and she'd say oh thank you thank you
and the reason was because as soon as
she said I love you back she knew that
this was gonna be everything exactly so
she said I love you back and naturally
the first words out of my mouth war so
let's get marriage oh that's good right
and she said no let's take our time
it'll be fine I said you understand this
is not fun okay like that the part is
like when we get married that's the fun
part because now we're committed now I
don't have to worry about everything
falling apart right now this is
extremely nerve-wracking get this thing
off the table
that would be great I mean I've never
understood the desire to sort of delay
marriage once you found the person who
you think you want to be with yeah yeah
I this this this is a little random but
I have a one of my son's friends came
home from college and his his girlfriend
had come home from college and over
Christmas I was saying to them hey how's
things going like they're great you know
we want to get engaged we want to get
married next year and and and we're both
going to take our next semester of
school in Europe and I was like wait a
minute you're gonna get married a year
from now but you go into Europe like
next semester I'm like there's a way too
romantic of a place to not go while
you're married like come on so he
actually made the plans and I married
them like a week later Wow like no joke
but this vacation was over and I'm not
even a minister so but I got ordained we
went to the to the Presidential Library
and and it was drizzling rain outside
but we just walked up with some flowers
and if I pronounce you man and wife and
off they went through Paris that is
awesome so you've been married for
almost three decades so what are your
keys to marriage to making a marriage
last cuz obviously evaporated in the
Hollywood world where marriages last an
average about 13
so what exactly are the keys here I know
I say it all the time like I've been
married 29 years which is like 290 in
Hollywood years and it's mostly because
I have a very forgiving wife I have an
angel wife she truly is amazing ask
anybody who knows her but uh you know I
think I think it's the thing we all know
at the end of the day we can see
selfishness in our spouse much easier
than we can see it in ourselves and when
I'm focusing on me and mine and my needs
and my wants and all that stuff that's
the perfect conditions for a rebellion
but I think when I'm when I say you know
what it's you before me how can I serve
you if I can do that and I need God's
help to do that because I'm selfish by
nature then I promote a revival in my
marriage that's what I want and so with
this marriage and parenting conference
that I that I'm that I'm hosting those
are the kinds of things we talk about
forgiveness how do you cherish your
spouse you know me misery others joy
those are the kinds of things that are
hard because it goes against the the
sort of the selfish nature within us you
know I deserve this what have you done
for me you know I deserve better than
that but at the end of the day I know
that I want I'm still a work in progress
I'm not finished don't put the inspector
inspection sticker on me yet and so I
don't want to do that to you either
what's been the most common problem that
you've encountered from people at your
seminars talking about marriage most
common problem selfishness infidelity
you know I mean that's that's just such
a hard one right you know when when when
something as sacred and intimate as a
marriage relationship gets gets violated
in that kind of a way it's it's it's so
hard to put the pieces back it's so hard
to trust again you get wounded and
injured the walls go up and those are
often I think the most difficult things
obviously communication and money issues
are our big ones but it's interesting
you know often when when we're dating
our spouse or our girlfriend or
boyfriend you know if we don't have any
money we're just sitting on the floor of
an empty apartment eating pizza out of a
box with no money to buy anything better
we're good that's for
we don't have money problems you know we
can look at each other and gaze into one
another's eyes for hours without saying
a word and we got no communication
problems but when selfishness creeps in
you know and it's like when you're
spending the money that I made and and
and all of a sudden communications a
problem intimacy is a problem money's a
problem and so I think it's the
selfishness thing it's the me monster it
always ends up being the culprit and not
to give the Hebrew biblical scriptural
analysis the word for the word for for
love in Hebrews Ahava and the root of
that word is hob which is the same as to
give so the root of love is to give
meaning that obviously if you're giving
first then then your marriage is okay
I've always felt that when when people
call into my show and ask about this
sort of thing the first thing that I
always say is if you have all the
expectations of yourself but none of
your spouse you'll have a good marriage
and if you married the right person then
that won't ruin the marriage people seem
to think that if you expect a lot of
yourself and nothing from your spouse
your spouse is gonna go like usually
there's in the court everything go but
if you married the right person they're
thinking the same thing that the
expectation is on them and they don't
expect of you and that's that's good
that means that there are two people who
are ready to answer any problem as
opposed to two people neither of whom
wants to answer the problem in both of
them are pointing fingers
yeah that's such a good point and and
that's one of the one of the messages
that came out of that movie fireproof
was even if you haven't married the
right person if I can try to get my part
right maybe maybe I I will be used as
sort of a vessel to bring about change
in my spouse over time I can't force it
but maybe I can lead by example and
that'll bring some sort of
transformation to my relationship if I'm
patient I mean this is gonna sound kind
of sexist but it's not meant to be I I
firmly believe my wife believes this to
do so it's not that sexist with that the
the strength of a good marriage really
relies on the man meaning that women
tend to be more attuned to what takes to
make a good marriage men tend to be less
attuned to that and so the marriage is
only gonna be as good as the man is
toward the woman he's the way for the
marriage yeah exactly yeah and so if so
if he's strong and you can have a strong
marriage exactly so you have six kids
which is unthinkable for me I have two
right now I have full up and we have a
third coming in March so we're not quite
full up but I that's gonna be
interesting and hopefully we'll have
more after that because that's six and
they're all within you said a six-year
span a seven-year span yeah they're all
about one year apart so when they were
little
think it's just think of this so you
know my wife's got the double stroller
the front pack the back pack while I'm
traveling at work so so one six ones
five four three two and a newborn this
is the kind of amazing wife that I'm
married to and and now let me help I
mean I just have to ask like you you
know I mean my mom would come over
sometimes that we never actually never
had a nanny and really it's we could
have used some help but I think Chelsea
was just always so all-in that it was
like that's what she wanted her hands
full of all the time and she still does
she thinks that that's like the most
beautiful wonderful thing in the whole
world
how could I ask for any more to being a
mom and so and to be there for all those
little moments is just something she
treasured which I'm thankful for and as
they've gotten older I'm just warning
you it doesn't really get easier so if
you okay it's different you're not up
feeding them you know bottles you're up
worrying that they're gonna get home
alive at night so now our kids are 22 21
20 19 18 and 17 so one's married some
have moved out they're driving you have
boyfriends it's it's a whole new world
he said four of those kids are adopted
so how do you always make the decision
to adopt well my wife is actually an
adopted child herself and so that was
always a beautiful part of her story and
when we had been married for about six
years we talked about having a family
and we were working a lot when we first
got married and then we said well what
about adoption like why don't we look
into adoption and I thought that was a
great idea I thought I don't need to be
the DNA DNA donor there's kids who need
a dad and a mom so we got in touch with
an agency and we adopted our son Jack
and it was such a great experience for
us and for them that they said there's
another little girl that is needing a
home and so Bella was adopted and then a
year later it was Anna and then it was
Luke and so we had four and then all of
a sudden Chelsea says to me hey I think
the kitchen that the bathroom sink is
broken would you go look at it and so
that was my chance to strap on my tool
belt and be score some husband points
walk in there and I look at the sink I
couldn't tell what was wrong I look
underneath the sink I couldn't see
what's wrong I I go up to the faucets
and I see this little this little like
popsicle stick shaped
test it says positive and I'm like what
are you trying to say pregnant and so
then Olivia was born and then a year
later the sink broke again and James is
born so then we have sacrum said okay
all right we got it we got it we got to
think about what's going on here why
this is happening and we can get that
right exactly but we stopped at a
half-dozen then so what are some of the
lessons in parenting this one I
definitely take from you so right now as
I say I have a five year old a three
year old and one who has yet to be born
and it's as you say it gets more
complicated
it's either different it's it's easier
in some ways because you don't worry so
much the kids are gonna stick a fork in
the in the electric socket right but at
the same time they have new problems
they have new issues then you know you
go to school then all the sudden you
import everybody else's problems when
they come home yeah I mean what are the
worst of the pieces of advice you have
for for parents as the kids start to get
older well thank you for asking I'm
certainly not an expert in this but one
of the things that the three keys that
Chelsea and I have always come back to
and when we when we're up at night going
o have a horrible parent you know have I
done this right we come back to these
three things and one is I want to strive
to be the kind of person I want my
children to become more is caught than
taught kids naturally play
follow-the-leader so your son your
daughter can be looking at you going
what does daddy do what does mom do and
they like to copy us you know that's why
he likes to walk around in your shoes or
likes to pick up your briefcase and so
if I want my kids to be joyful if I want
my kids to be compassionate if I want my
kids to trust God in difficult
circumstances model it for them Shawn
what it looks like so that they don't
have to figure it out or imagine it they
can say oh yeah that's what my dad did
that's why mom did and when I mess up
ask them for forgiveness some people
think that would be weak to ask
forgiveness from your kids but that's
actually modeling for them the strength
that you need to be humble when you make
a mistake you know those are the kinds
of things along with keeping their
keeping their heart understanding that
relationship is the most important thing
sometimes a house can easily turn into a
Correctional Facility you know and it's
just
you know say please say thank you sit
down don't do that when when really
while those are important at the end of
the day we're all gonna make mistakes
and and and if I lose the heart of my
child I've lost the battle they're gonna
ice me out they're not gonna listen
they're gonna go somewhere else where
they feel like somebody listens cares
for them and so keeping that
relationship strong through the good
times to the difficult times I think is
is paramount and then point them to
truth you know I mean the kids get
inundated with so much error with so
much you know right is wrong wrong is
right and for me I go to God's Word
those those those principles those
ancient truths that I can always go to
you know you talked about the Hebrew
Scriptures and the book of Proverbs how
how amazing is the book of Proverbs to
go back in there and say what what what
are the what are the what are the
time-tested principles that always
produce blessing and good things and
protection I want my kids to learn those
things and know that that truth is not
relative when it comes to morality and
things like that truth is something that
they can build their life on in this
seems to be one of the areas where our
society is really going off the rails is
this belief that we should raise our
kids in sort of roof sewing in fashion
just let them free in the wilderness and
then they can discover their own values
and I've noticed that society
particularly these days wants to do this
with everything related to boys and
girls they want to suggest that kids are
going to basically form their own values
in every particular but it's not just
that it's pretty much with everything
they find their own religious values and
that if you inculcate any sort of values
in your kids you're actually acting as a
tyrant than what you actually should be
doing is allowing their brains that are
that are unformed to just experience the
world taking those perceptions and then
form their own value systems it seems to
be not working particularly well for the
society at large so what are what are
the some values they do wanna make Wow I
mean yeah I mean that doesn't work for
any other any other discipline right
like if you're going to go into law do
you say hey figure it all out I know
you're gonna go to law school you're
gonna learn understand the principles
you know people can go to war you're
gonna train them on on the principles of
how to how to you use use you know the
weapons and things like that
not just figuring out on their own so
the values that I want to teach my kids
I
our values like trusting in God virtue
and character and considering other
people more important than yourself I
think those are the nation those are the
values that that not only make human
beings flourish individually make them
pleasant people but it makes families
flourish it makes marriages flourish and
I think that's what makes a nation
flourish I think these are the
principles that our country was built on
and every time that we get away from
those things we suffer and you know we
we we go the wrong direction and we can
tell by the consequences that the law of
cause and effect that this isn't working
well so I want to teach my kids those
those ancient truths and those those
judeo-christian principles and that
worldview that led to the freest most
blessed and prosperous nation the
world's ever known so in a second I want
to ask you about the biggest mistake you
think you've made as a parent okay
that's kind of a rough question all I
see that one second but first how often
have you seen these horrible news
stories where some actress gets hacked
and then her nude photos are online well
two things you should know about that
one do not take photos of yourself in
the nude on your phone it's just dumb
and 2 anyone can be hacked if you think
hackers only target large companies to
get your information wrong I use
expressvpn myself to safeguard my
personal data online so should these
actresses according to recent reports
hackers can make up to $1,000 from
selling someone's personal information
on the dark web making people like me
and you easy and lucrative targets
expressvpn it's an app for your computer
and phone when secures and encrypts your
data so you can have peace of mind every
time you go online the app connects with
just one click it's lightning fast
here's the best part
expressvpn cost less than seven bucks a
month listen if a breach can happen to
Capital One or to Scarlett Johansson it
can easily happen to an individual like
you protect yourself with expressvpn
then number one VPN rated by tech radar
seen at the verge and countless others
and you should protect yourself with
expressvpn why would you leave your data
out there for anybody to grab use my
special link expressvpn comm slash Ben
right now you can arm yourself with an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free support the show keep your
information safe
that's expressvpn comm slash Ben for an
extra three months free let's talk about
like the biggest mistakes that you've
made as a parent so for me when one of
the things that I've been noticing is
the scariest thing in the world is the
mic
taking everything I do this it's it's
terrifying to me this is only beginning
to dawn on me now because before they
were you know 2 & 4 1 & 3 and they
weren't really taking everything in now
if I let a curse word slip the chances
that it will be in the next sentence
were to have my child are least 127
percent and so I've been noticing that
every bad thing that I do immediately
comes back to me and so it highlights
all the worst parts of you don't
actually get to see the best parts of
you so much yet see all the worst things
that you do immediately mirrored back at
you and it's scaring the living so
you've been a parent a lot longer than I
have so whatever would have been some of
the things that you wish she hadn't done
I feel like I've been true I've done a
lot of bad things I've done I've made a
lot of mistakes see you need to ask this
question to my wife she could tell you
or my son James is he's sitting right
over here he could probably tell you the
biggest mistakes I've made
but I'm so gun shy to really talk about
machine mistakes that I've made on on a
worldwide on the worldwide web because
everyone loves to exploit those things
you know you slip up with one thing and
it's just like look at how horrible that
so I think I'd be a little bit more time
yeah no worries I mean I hear that I
mean it is it is a very since aureus
culture right now I will put kid
pictures of my kids up and I was talking
this morning on social media about how
my kids have finally gotten into Star
Wars which is fun because nobody can
share that and so we've been having
lightsaber battles me and my
five-year-old
and we have we have it all on video and
it's adorable but I can't put that up on
social media because my people are
horrible and they they will go after
your kids and it really is terrible so
you're somebody who's been in the public
eye longer than I have and how are you
able to maintain protection I mean
there's really an advice question how
are you able to maintain protection of
your kids being in the public eye as
much as you are somehow we were able to
really just not have pictures of our
kids or anything on the internet for the
longest time now once our kids had
phones and they've got throw an
Instagram account you know they're
wanting to post as much as they can and
now that our kids are older it's a bit
different but but yeah we've very
similar to the way that you and your
wife feel about that we wanted to
protect our kids I'm like if someone's
gonna get upset with me get upset with
me if someone wants to show up at you
know and and you know have a
conversation with me like I don't want
you to know where I live and actually
you know have my kids answer the door or
have you come after my kids or say mean
things about them so we
we just we just kept that real quiet I
was really diligent about it and I think
it turned out okay so I think when
people look at religious people I got a
faith ear a person of faith but when
people look at religious people they
tend to think at least in the secular
community look at that happy idiot look
at that look at that guy he's just so
happy all the time doesn't he understand
that we are all going to suffer that we
are all going to die that things are bad
in the world have that haven't they ever
struggled with faith and it's point of
high era tation for me as a person of
faith because I've yet to meet a person
who's actually religious who's never
struggled at all with faith so what are
some of the ways in which you've
struggled with your own faith over the
years and the ways that I've struggled
with my faith over the years you know
ii-i've never wanted to be someone who
believed in fairy tales or be accused of
some as of be accused of being someone
who believes in fairy tales and coming
from an atheistic background or just a
sort of like secular humanist background
I wanted to really make sure and so I I
felt like have I really examined all the
evidence how can it be someone like Sam
Harris or how can I have these other
people who are so intelligent clearly
you know they've got a size 10 brain and
and mine's not that that size but I
believe that that if I sincerely do the
best that I can if I have faith if I
believe and I ask God I believe he's
kind enough to reveal himself to me and
so I have struggled with the sort of the
the the intellect and the reason versus
versus the faith and I don't think that
they're pitted against one another by
any means in fact I think they they go
very well together but sometimes I get
into pitting them against one another
and wondering you know is there is there
some stone I've not yet uncovered to to
so unravel everything that I that I
believe and the more and more that I
examine those things and I ask those
deep questions the more and more I
believe that my faith in God has been
well placed and when it comes to your
kids are all of your kids people of
faith as well you know I think they're
yes I would say so
they certainly grew up with a lot of
faith in our home but that's something
that's so personal
that I can say we go to church or we
don't go to church or this or that but
in terms of like a living vibrant
relationship with God where I talk to
God I I believe that God directs me
that's something that's so personal that
I think it's it's sort of on a you know
it's it's something that's in seed form
with some of our kids and it's something
that's maturing and bearing fruit with
others so you talked a little bit
earlier about the values that undergird
the country when we look at the state of
the country now it's it's so divisive
everybody seems to be at each other's
throats what do you think is the biggest
problem facing the country in terms of
the country coming it feels like it's
coming apart wow I I want to ask you
that question
now your your more position to answer
that and and and I feel I feel like
maybe my role in the public square you
know sometimes I wonder I know why does
anybody care what what Mike Seaver has
to say after all of these years you know
why am I sitting here with with you and
and and I think that that I've been
given a platform and and perhaps my role
is to continue to point people not
toward the specific details of what's
getting everybody fighting with one
another but point them higher to the
larger principles at play that
historically have given us a country
where we can debate about these things
and we can have respectful conversations
and discourse about these things without
killing each other over it and we have
freedom of speech and freedom of
religion and and we have these things
that we all love and and so I'm not sure
if I could point to one particular issue
but I can point to the principles that
will solve that issue and I think that's
why I'm trying to focus my energy not on
everything that interests me or
fascinates me but on the areas where I
think I'm uniquely positioned to make a
difference and that's why I made a
documentary called monumental or movie
like fireproof and I'm doing these
marriage and parenting things you still
have a lot of friends in Hollywood
obviously and are there I know there's
some conservatives in Hollywood are
there any religious people like what
would people be shocked to learn how
many religious people or were they shot
to be learned how few religious people
that are in Hollywood yet that's a good
question
I think that I mean it's amazing to me
when you grow up in Los Angeles you had
this impression that there are nope not
very many people of faith eat not just
in Los Angeles but like around the world
like like atheism is dominating the
world and that's just not true the
statistics that I've read are that that
well over 90 percent of the world is
very religious different religions but
people are people of faith and so here
in Hollywood I think that there are more
people of faith than you would think
or that that people would think but many
of them are very cautious about
expressing that faith many people think
that like what I've done like talking
about my faith would be sort of suicide
for a career yeah but I have faith in a
faithful God who's opened up doors so
that I can continue doing what I love
and I think it's really helping people
and and so I think more and more people
of faith you'll see coming out of the
closet and not just in Hollywood but all
around the the country in the world
people are making projects where faith
is at the center because it does well at
the box office and so I think that's
encouraging and drawing people out
rather than being afraid of the
faithless in Hollywood I mean this is
one of the the questions that I've
gotten a lot from conservative friends
mind in Hollywood is how quiet should I
keep this should I come out of the
closet and just be conservative and
honestly I've had to say it's it's a it
really is a question for you to answer
because only I don't know the risk
factors involved with your career and
with your and and using an income and
with your kids in all of this but I mean
you do see the social sanctions that are
brought to bear on people just for going
to a particular church I remember Chris
Pratt going to a church that was
considered Pro traditional marriage
suddenly he was getting all sorts of
flack even though he never made a
statement on the issue one way or
another and so the idea of people in
Hollywood just beginning to come out and
say yes I'm a person of faith I go to
church regularly I'm a Bible believer it
seems like the social sanctions are
incredibly strong so what would your
advice be to people who haven't done
what you've done and just come out and
said listen here's Who I am and here's
what I believe in deal with it
personally you only live once right you
know you only live once and I would say
go with your convictions you know yeah I
don't want to look back and go wow wish
I could do that over again you know I
just I wish I had some courage and I
wish I didn't care so much about what
other people thought I people which is
why I want to try to
beak the truth and live the truth in a
compassionate way and if I don't do that
I'm really not loving people I'm really
just sort of protecting myself in my
career which is selfish so I say go with
your convictions you only live once like
do what you believe you're here to do so
I don't mean to sound selfish but you
brought me a gift I've heard that there
is a gift yes I did I'll wait I'm a I'm
very eager to give it to you okay
excellent that is amazing and also large
that is incredible and large and what
what is this okay so I'm gonna I'll tell
you what this is so I made a documentary
several years ago called monumental in
which I retrace the escape route of the
pilgrims and the reason I made it was
not for political reasons but as a dad
I'm going our country is is seems to be
like going down the tubes so what do we
need to do well the left blames the
right the right blames the left the the
poor blame the rich the rich blame the
poor I'm thinking why can't we just go
back to what made this country so unique
in the first place so I went and
retraced the escape route of the
pilgrims to figure out who they were
what did they do why did they come here
and I learned that these were the the
free thinking out-of-the-box faithful
people who came here to do something
that that in their minds had not been
tried successfully for three thousand
years since the ancient Hebrew republic
under the leadership of Moses I mean you
know they felt that the ancient Hebrews
were given the divine constitution in
the Torah and they wanted to import
those principles of liberty and justice
to the New World
so our pilgrim forefathers and
foremothers left us what I call the the
the secret sauce recipe for how to build
a free and just society under the Word
of God
and they left it for us in the form of
this monument which the real one is 81
feet tall
it's a hundred and eighty tons of solid
granite it's the largest granite
monument in America and it's invisible
nobody knows it's there it's hidden
behind a forest of trees in Plymouth
Massachusetts today and it spells out
all the principles that you and I love
and this is a replica of it so that
people can see it
you've probably never heard of it it's
called the national monument to the
forefathers and I I hired the wet a
workshop who does all the sculptor
things to capture all of the detail and
if I can't please explain it to you
please I would love that
okay all right this is awesome okay I
can't wait to explain this to you so
history tells us that our forefathers
and foremothers believe this that to
have a functioning society that was free
you had to start with what's this era
here faith and faith is the largest of
all of these figures and she's pointing
to heaven and she's got a book in her
hand it happens to be the Bible that was
the Geneva Bible brought over by the
pilgrims on the Mayflower
her feet are on a rock and that's pill a
Plymouth Rock and she has a star on her
forehead representing wisdom and so they
would reason from the scriptures to
create their society now check this out
faith is then expressed in these four
key ways number one it's first expressed
through morality and morality is
depicted as a woman here holding the Ten
Commandments in her left hand and the
scroll of Revelation in her right hand
and that represents both the old and the
new testament but they believe that
morality was not something that could be
imposed externally by a king or a tyrant
so on the left it says evangelist and
they believe that that that that God's
Word needed to be needed to be
proclaimed so that there was a
transformation of the heart that the
grace of God would change you on the
inside so then you love the standard on
the outside once you had good morality
then you could make good laws in your
nation and there's the judge he's
sitting on his his chair and he's
holding the book of law and his book is
directly beneath the book in faiths hand
which is the scriptures signifying that
man's laws must line up under God's laws
or they're not good laws and on his
right it's justice on his left is mercy
so there had to be a balance between
justice and mercy
once you have civility in your in your
society then you can educate your kids
and there's a mother there or a parent
who's wearing the wreath of victory
holding the book of knowledge and on her
right it goes right back to the book of
Proverbs
there's the youth because they believe
that if you train up your child in the
way they should go when they're old and
here's the old man with a long white
beard he's holding a globe and a Bible
when he's old he'll not depart from it
and his name is wisdom so he has a
biblical worldview once you have that to
the 2nd and 3rd generation they believe
you come up with the result which is
Liberty and that was both Liberty
internally from sin pride arrogance
selfishness and liberty externally from
tyrants and bad government and if you
look he's the chains on his ankles and
his wrists are broken tyrannies been
overthrown and his wife is here next to
him her name is peace and she's holding
a basket full of good things for her
friends her family and her community so
this was the secret sauce recipe and
it's there for everybody to see and and
these are the kinds of values that I
love and I want to point people to when
was this built this was actually
completed in 1859 I believe it took 50
years to build and it was actually
interrupted by a little thing called the
civil war and it was interesting because
Abraham Lincoln was one of the very
first contributors to the building of
this Monument and there was an architect
Hammett Billings who actually did the
drawings for Uncle Tom's Cabin and it
was it was it was an amazing time that
this was built and it is still the
largest granite monument in America and
it's invisible nobody's ever heard of it
and you can't find it unless you know if
less I tell you where to go that's
unbelievable so yeah what is it about
our culture that gets all this so wrong
I mean they now every Thanksgiving
there's a there's a big fuss over the
Pilgrims and how the Pilgrims were
actually oppressors and how then this
civilization coming to this this
hemisphere was it was a bad thing where
where are we missing the boat here I'm
not sure I'm not sure exactly Ben I'm
not exactly sure but I think that if I
think often people find what they're
looking for you know and and if I'm
looking for these kinds of principles I
can find them I can find them
particularly in history and when I go
back and I look in at cultures and
nations that abide by these kinds of
principles and values good things result
every time we get away from them bad
things result so you know if faith is in
God and Liberty is the reserve
old boy if we put our faith in the state
or faith in the government or faith in
in something other than the kindest most
benevolent person in the universe I
think what happens is it changes your
morality
it changes the laws that you pass in
your nation you teach those things to
your kids and you don't end up with
Liberty Man as the result you end up
with the the lion of tyranny and Liberty
man's leg hanging out of the lion's
mouth and I fear that that so many
nations have gone that way and that we
may go the same if we don't get back to
what works well I'm gonna spend a moment
figuring out where to put this in my
house I'm thinking my wife nightstand
but I don't know it looks right over
there so I actually have a smaller one
for you mondo gigantic one I guess I
have one that's half this size and this
one is I want to give this one to the
president I want to give one to the vice
president too all politicians presidents
of universities ministers and parents
who want to teach these things to their
kids what if I what if I use it as sort
of an imposing intimidation factor for
my children so they send one they do
something that could work and they just
wake up and they will end it's right
next to but it's right they open their
eyes in the morning and there's their
faith just looking directly I say you
that correct correct in a second I want
to ask you about the the kind of old
conservative question whether whether
culture is upstream of politics or
politics is upstream of culture I'm
gonna ask you about that in just one
second first are you tired
I'm tired I'll try I'm tired and that
means that right now I would love
nothing better than to go home and slip
between my incredible bull and branch
sheets okay these sheets sound great you
never think about your sheets right you
think about everything else think about
the matter is maybe the pillow and the
temperature in the room you never think
about the sheets the sheets will make a
huge difference in how you sleep in your
me sleeping on them every night we could
all use more sleep and getting a great
night's sleep is easier and more
affordable than you think
you don't need a new expensive mattress
or sleeping pills you need to change the
sheets that's why you should check out
ball and branch everything ball and
branch makes from bedding to blankets
it's made from pure 100% organic cotton
it means they start out super soft they
get even softer over time you can buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to $1,000 in the store bull
and bran
she's only a couple of hundred bucks
they're great I mean they're so good
that I've literally replaced all of the
sheets in my house with ball and branch
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund that's not gonna
happen you're gonna want to keep them to
get you started right now my listeners
get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets at bull and branch calm promo
code bettin go to bull and branch calm
today for 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets that's bol and branch calm promo
clip and these are the best sheets on
the market I know you don't think about
sheets a lot but now you are so go get
the good ones go to bull and branch calm
promo code Ben okay so I won't ask you
because you're so engaged in in the
culture whether you think that at this
point you know the future of America
rests in a change to culture or change
to politics and this is a really sort of
a raging debate even within the right in
in recent days one of my old mentors
Andrew Breitbart used to say culture is
upstream of politics that you gotta work
first on changing the culture that's
what Hollywood did so successfully they
changed the way that we think about the
world and then politics necessarily
follow it how we thought about the world
and then there are a lot of people who
believe know the culture has been
largely lost and the only way to restore
the culture is by grabbing the high
reins of politics and then trying to
almost cram down your viewpoints or
instill your viewpoint through the
education system what do you think do
you think that if you're a conservative
and you have a hundred bucks to spend
you're gonna give it away this year
should you be trying to put it into sort
of politics or should you be trying to
put it into either your church on the
one hand or into like actual cultural
pursuits that are not necessarily just
your church so being a guy who's in the
entertainment industry I'm not saying
this just because I work in this space
but I really do think that Instagram and
Facebook is influencing my children more
than just about anything else that I can
I can think of in the political world so
I think that that politics is downstream
of culture as you as you've mentioned I
think that the hearts and minds of young
people are being formed and then they
vote accordingly they pull those people
in and then they pass those laws
accordingly that's why I think that we
need good people in the entertainment
industry in the places where stories are
being told that are capturing the hearts
and minds of people so while people may
say like hey let's let's let's get out
of Hollywood right that
that's a dark place that's a dirty place
they you know they generate a lot of
filth well III think I think it's it's
kind of like politics you know if you
don't like it change it so come on in
and we need people who are going to
assume positions of leadership in the
entertainment industry in the
storytelling world because that's what
our kids are listening to the music and
movies and television and the arts and
and then they they seem to want to you
know bring those values to bear in in in
the legal world and the political world
so when it comes to your own parenting
how did you engage your kids in
entertainment how did you decide what
you're okay with your kids watching and
what you weren't okay with your kids
watching well when our kids were little
we never wanted them to feel like they
had celebrity parents and so while there
would be an occasional hey can I have
your autograph
we really didn't bring our kids into
that world and accordingly we didn't
watch growing you know they didn't there
wasn't a box set of growing pains
episodes in our house that we watched it
was I Love Lucy
it was the Brady Bunch and my kids
really they really grew up on I Love
Lucy I mean that that's where a lot of
my kids they their sense of humor is is
Lucy you know shoot she was just
hilarious and then interestingly none of
my kids have really shown a strong
interest in getting involved in the
entertainment industry so my son my son
James I don't know he the jury's still
out he still may be interested he's
pretty much of a of an entertainer and a
ham so he might follow in my footsteps
but but we never really embraced the the
Hollywood lifestyle in the Hollywood
circles of friends we kind of lived on
the outskirts we kind of live in more of
a rural area for Los Angeles and we
spent our time outside in the mountains
hiking going to the beach you know
playing in the mud with our kids much
more so than really being part of of
that entertainment industry scene one of
the interesting debates that's broken
out on the right is is also debate about
sort of what is okay to watch as a
religious person or as a conservative so
I have friends like David French and
David is is very religious he was a
lawyer for the Alliance defending
freedom and he's filed lawsuit on behalf
of religious freedom over the country he
served in Iraq really good
but and David on the one hand will be
like yeah I'll watch Game of Thrones and
I'll try and take a good message out of
Game of Thrones and then we obviously
employment Walsh here and Matt Walsh
says that we should all burn our
television sets so where do you come
down where do you come down on unsorted
what do you think it's appropriate for
religious people to watch or how do you
think religious people should should
engage with entertainment yeah that's a
great question obviously you're not
going to open up the Bible and it's
going to tell you what shows you
shouldn't shouldn't watch so I think I
think that there's principles so I'm
always looking as as I want to have
integrity and I think integrity means
Who I am in public is going to is the
same as Who I am in private that I'm not
I'm not I don't have dual personalities
and you know when I when I'm watching
television or I'm listening to music I
want to be the same person that I'm
gonna be even when I'm in front of my
kids because I think like I want my
whole life done I got the whole the
whole thing I want it all to be there so
so for us actually the televisions just
rarely on in our house so for us we're
watching The Voice or a basketball game
or a football game and we're watching
you know chopped because we like to cook
and but that's those are sort of the
staples in our house not so much the
sitcoms or or the one-hour dramas or
Lord of the Rings we've probably seen
all of those and you know a million
times over so given your sort of
entertainment taste what do you guys do
in your off hours I mean it's funny I
rarely see movies like I don't even
really like to go see movies I'll go see
movies my friends in or something that's
important I'll go see it but in our off
hours it's really kind of boring which
is we like being home we just like being
with each other I travel quite a bit and
so when I'm home like this month has
just been awesome I've been home for a
whole month and so I'm putting up
Christmas lights I'm weeding in the
garden I'm like scoring so many husband
points by cooking for my wife and then
she's an amazing cook but I'm just like
honey just let me go in the kitchen for
a month and I'm just making fantastic
things this Bobby Flay burger that I
came that I came across he's awesome you
got to make it for your wife she'll love
it okay well when first of all I could
definitely use to score some of those
points so that's that sounds perfect
I'll definitely heat up for that rest
okay I'll give you I'll give you the
cooking they're the
app that I use it's great yeah so you've
been watching sort of the era of me too
and one of the things that's been
interesting to watch has been how
Hollywood has dealt with me too because
obviously me to started in Hollywood and
then Hollywood has immediately decided
that it's Hollywood's place to lecture
the rest of America on May 2 which has
been quite amusing the same people who
held up Harvey Weinstein is a moral hero
for four decades have now decided that
they get to at the Oscars explain to the
rest of America exactly how terrible it
is to matron astray women which some of
us already actually knew yeah you've had
you've had this rule for for quite a
while that you won't kiss any woman who
is not your wife on screen are off so
how when it when did you decide to
implement that rule given the fact
you're an actor
yeah I think when I got married I think
it was just husband 101 for me it was
pretty pretty simple I I made a promise
to my wife at the altar and I figure
like you know other than being an actor
guys don't have this understanding with
their wives that they get to go to work
and kiss other women that they're not
married to but sort of like everybody
gets a free pass in my business and I
was like no my wife's not into that
that's not a good idea I want I want a
great marriage and so ever come up have
you ever been reading a script and all
of a sudden there was something worried
because yeah it's not yeah and so not
not often but but if it has and yeah
there's been other times I'm like I'm
like you get so many more people to go
do this scene I mean and it's usually
not just kissing right it's like you're
in bed with somebody right I mean it and
so but you know it's something that's
paid great dividends in my marriage you
know and and believe me I I'm so
thankful to have a wife who still loves
me after 29 years I want to do
everything that I can to honor her and
you know I think I think everybody would
like to have the confidence and the
trust in their spouse that even when
they're not around
they're that they're that they are who
they think they are you know and that's
and that's really what I'm striving to
be so I want to ask you about this
amazing new pro-life movie that you're
coming out if you're telling me a little
bit about it before the show and it
sounds incredible but if you want to
hear about it you have to go over to
Daley wire calm slash subscribe give us
your money and you can hear the end of
our conversation over there thank you so
much for coming by I really appreciate
it thank you great to talk to you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy Boren associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Manor post-production is supervised by
Alex Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike her Amina hair
and makeup is by Jesuit alvera title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20